in September 2019 the FTC reached a
settlement with YouTube regarding their
violation of the Children's Online
Privacy Protection Act or Coppa the
ultra short summary is that under Coppa
you're not allowed to collect
identifying data from children 12 and
under without verifiable parental
consent what the complaint alleged was
that while YouTube was claiming to be
Coppa compliant by restricting their
platform to individuals 13 and older
they did in fact knowingly gather vast
rows of data from children 12 and under
market YouTube to content creators as
the dominant platform in children's
entertainment and used the collected
data to shape a behaviorally targeted ad
network that they actively sold to child
directed content creators with corporate
channels operated by Hasbro and Mattel
being specifically named in the
complaint as part of the settlement with
the FTC YouTube has agreed to pay 170
million dollars for these violations and
to institute a system whereby channel
operators voluntarily identify child
directed content at which point
information gathering features will be
disabled on those videos or channels
YouTube has subsequently implemented two
new systems the first is as directed a
system that requires channel owners to
indicate if their content is child
directed colloquially for kids this flag
can be set at the channel owners
discretion on a video by video basis or
as a channel wide setting this is the
system the settlement mandated the
second is an algorithm driven automated
system that seeks out potentially child
directed content and automatically Flags
it for kids the exact operation of this
system has not been disclosed to channel
owners however it is safe to assume it
includes analyzing language used in the
title and description and a measure of
image analysis of the video itself
possibly language analysis of the
soundtrack YouTube is not required to do
this they have implemented this
voluntarily an element that they have
loudly proclaimed in an effort at
positioning themselves as eager and
willing to go above and beyond in
complying with the settlement
additionally the FTC has stated that
they consider channel owners on YouTube
to be what Coppa defines as operators
which is to say that an individual
YouTube channel should be viewed in the
same classification as a website such as
My Little Pony calm with YouTube merely
functioning as the host under this
classification channel owners are
strictly liable for copic compliance on
any child directed content and may be
subject to fines exceeding 40 thousand
US per infringing video in practical
terms an infringing video is one that is
child directed but has not been properly
flagged as such again it's worth
remembering that the FTC's primary
examples in forming this opinion where
YouTube channels operated by existing
corporate entities manufacturing child
directed content and products such as
Hasbro Mattel Nickelodeon and Disney on
the whole I absolutely agree that there
was in fact wrongdoing on the part of
YouTube and on the part of several child
directed channels the FTC's complaint
and the resulting settlement are
absolutely well-founded there are
undeniable problems in how YouTube
handles children's entertainment that
need to be addressed and in that
solution channel owners without question
bear some responsibility in ensuring
that child directed content is produced
and delivered with due respect for the
privacy of their audience I would like
to focus however
on where the implementation of this
agreement has gone wrong resulting in a
substantial disruption in operation for
a wide range of channels that bear only
superficial similarities to actual child
directed content the automated systems
that YouTube has implemented aligns with
what Commissioner Rebecca slaughter
called a technological backstop an
automated system to identify
undesignated child directed content and
turn off behavioral advertising in her
dissenting statement on the settlement
Commissioner slaughter proposed such a
system as a mechanism to ensure that
content creators are telling the truth
when they designate their content as not
child directed in chairman Simons and
Commissioner Wilson's joint statement on
the settlement they acknowledge
Commissioner slaughters preference for a
technological backstop but Simon's and
Wilson dismissed the option as it would
be in their opinion an empty gesture
YouTube could easily develop a
half-hearted measure that would
technically comply with the order and
give the public a false sense of
security moreover such a measure likely
would catch in its net channels not
directed at children therefore limiting
content to other audiences while the
errors are resolved this is in effect
exactly what YouTube has done the system
that they have chosen to implement meets
the requirement of the settlement for a
system of self designation but
additionally goes further blood lis
implementing an algorithmically driven
system that automatically designates
content as for kids based on oblique
overly broad criteria this has had the
exact effect Simon's and Wilson foresaw
generating a huge volume of false
positives most notably in adult facing
channels that discuss all ages and
children's media from the perspective of
adults in the role of collectors
educators editorialists and
documentarians how this plays out for
channel owners on a day to day basis is
that it adds another automated detection
system that imposes action on the
channel immediately and without warning
a video that is miss detected as child
directed is instantly placed in the four
kids classification forcing channel
owners to either wait through the
appeals process or remove alter and
re-upload the video in order to have
their work seen youtubers rely on a
sophisticated network of recommendations
a system that is driven by a series of
abstract metrics colloquially referred
to as engagement engagement is tied to
viewer actions such as rating a video
leaving a comment subscribing to a
channel adding the video to a playlist
and viewing other videos from the same
channel in succession the for kids
classification removes several of these
systems from a video notably comments
subscriptions playlists and ratings
removing these directly limits the
degree to which a video can be engaged
with and thus its position within
YouTube's recommendations as working
professionally on YouTube is a highly
time-sensitive business with critical
windows for revenue generation
misidentification of content as child
directed at key times early in a videos
life can have disastrous impact on the
revenue of adult facing content
additionally misidentification of adult
facing content as child directed has and
will continue to lead to a substantial
quantity of content that is
inappropriate for
children being added to the four kids
classification while the appropriateness
of children's entertainment isn't the
purview of the FTC and is out of the
scope of Coppa it is a related issue
that is already being hotly debated on
the platform and it is worth considering
that YouTube's new automated system has
farther reaching impacts than just the
issues immediately at hand in rolling
out this system YouTube has been vague
with users generating a tremendous
amount of chaos uncertainty and
animosity that they have done little to
dispel but much to direct towards the
FTC itself seemingly intent on
overwhelming the Commission with a none
parsable volume of uninformed panic that
could serve to delay or soften the terms
of the agreement against them while the
Commission has recognized the existence
of all ages content and differentiated
to some degree between age-appropriate
and child directed YouTube has in their
communication with creators stressed an
overly vague definition of for kids with
overt stress on the possible penalties
this has led many users to conflate
YouTube's broad and ill-defined
definition of for kids with the FTC's a
conflation that YouTube has been silent
about addressing a folk narrative has
evolved among users where they have come
to believe that they are potentially
liable to the FTC for anything as small
as incidental inclusion of children's
characters in their videos or a mere
cosmetic overlap in interests as an
example the YouTube sub community of
adult craftspeople modifying children's
toys particularly fashion dolls using
sophisticated adult techniques including
caustic solvents razor blades power
tools and sewing machines has been led
to believe the simple overlap of dolls
as an interest category is sufficient to
not only have their channels labelled
for kids by YouTube's planned algorithm
but expose them to potential FTC action
if they appeal to have their full
monetization and engagement features
reinstated rather than create an
environment where child directed content
creators are worried about the
consequences of trying to circumvent the
four kids classification general
audience content creators are panicking
about the hypothetical consequences of
accurately describing their content
as not for kids some measure of
automated detection is likely necessary
to stay ahead of serial offenders like
child directed content Mills cranking
out Nursery Rhyme cartoons however the
application of this automated system on
a video by video basis paired with
confusing and vague directions for
channel owners has served only to
generate chaos
I want to explicitly acknowledge that
channel owners absolutely bear some
responsibility in compliance the
solution the FTC mandated requiring
channel owners to self identify child
directed content is a reasonable burden
however YouTube has additionally passed
much of their burden of compliance on to
channel owners as well and have done so
without giving channel owners the
appropriately granular mechanisms or
educational resources to make informed
conscious decisions about how data is
collected from and utilized on their
channels this burden is being borne
mostly not by corporate channels such as
Mattel Hasbro or Disney who do not rely
on YouTube for substantial revenue nor
buy-in arguably child directed
independent YouTube channels but by
channels producing all-ages content that
they have monetized with a good-faith
assumption that YouTube was telling the
truth about Coppa compliance that their
channels and the ads on them were being
served to an audience aged 13 Plus while
YouTube could simply remove child
directed advertising from their
behavioral ad model entirely or use
their clearly demonstrated ability to
discern under 13 viewers and disable
behavioral advertising selectively at
the user level they have instead chosen
to structure their system to place the
burden and consequences overwhelmingly
on channel operators YouTube is in
effect trying to build a scenario where
they are still allowed to gather and
utilize children's data in serving
targeted behavioral ads with the blame
falling on channel owners for allowing
them to gather that information and
serve those ads channel owners do have
some granular control over the types of
ads that appear on their channels
however these controls are not contained
within the YouTube platform itself but
within its sister product Adsense and
for basic users these Adsense controls
do not include explicit age
targeting or exclusion only implicit
control based on large subject matter
categories by default all channels
except ads in all categories except
gambling and alcohol products in
practical terms the majority of YouTube
channels lack the resources to collect
meaningful audience data on their own
and are wholly reliant on the data that
YouTube chooses to share with them
because this data set does not include
information on children 12 and under the
vast majority of good-faith all-ages
content producers do not have actual
knowledge of their child audience and
would if provided the opportunity
willingly disabled behavioral ads
directed to children indeed many channel
owners assumed this was already the case
while it is possible for channel
operators to opt out of behavioral
advertising as a whole and limit their
ads to contextual ads only the controls
to do so are deeply hidden and as
Commissioner slaughter observed channel
owners are warned against doing so
because it may quote significantly
reduce your channels revenue it is worth
noting the channel owners are given no
additional data to verify that claim or
assess what YouTube considers to be a
significant reduction channel owners
perception of their incentives and
resulting behaviors are overwhelmingly
shaped by YouTube because YouTube
controls both access to and framing of
that information it is worth considering
to what degree channel owners are left
in the dark about where their interests
and YouTube's interests diverge lastly
while the FTC has determined that
individual YouTube channels are
operators under Coppa and thus have a
strict liability for compliance I don't
feel like that is an appropriate
one-size-fits-all descriptor well it
applies to many channels notably
corporate channels that have the
resources to maintain a self-contained
network of related content and negotiate
with YouTube directly as both
advertisers and content creators the
majority of channels simply must take
whatever YouTube chooses to give them
contrary to the Commission's framing
YouTube is not collecting data on my
behalf as an operator but is merely
allowing me to view a select slice of
that data that they collect regardless
of whether or not I choose to active
or deactivate behaviorally targeted ads
again it would be possible for YouTube
to address much of this compliance by
making alterations to their underlying
ads service if YouTube is
technologically capable of dynamically
serving behaviorally targeted ads to
children something they are demonstrably
capable of then they are equally capable
of using that information to disable
that users access to data collecting
features only serve contextual ads
remove ads altogether or direct the user
into YouTube kids YouTube has at its
disposal substantially more
sophisticated means to comply with the
Commission's agreement while voluntary
content flagging is useful and a good
measure and some measure of automated
detection is likely necessary YouTube's
response has been deliberately broad
utilizing their status as a monopoly in
online video to force creators to bear
the burdens of compliance without
providing them with the tools and data
to do so in a meaningful educated manner